pas vous suivez ces événements depuis le
départ du cortège place de la république
on est à présent place de la bastille
qu'en est il actuellement est ce que les
choses se calment
mais les choses se calment les pompiers
sont intervenus pour éteindre les
incendies qui avaient été allumés par
des manifestants et puis les forces de
l'ordre vous allez voir sur ces images
on véritablement resserrer le périmètre
à tel point qu'on peut dire que ils ont
regagné 7 place de la bastille après une
après midi très très tendue ici et dans
le cortège notamment sur dans la rue de
beaumarchés je suis avec david qui est
inscrite me dis que c'est comme ça qu'on
secourisme voilà c'est comme ça qu'on
les qualifie pas d'engagement politique
et vous me disiez que vous étiez venu en
aide à des forces de l'ordre parce qu'on
l'a dit on l'a répété pendant tout cet
après midi ils ont essuyé de nombreux
jets de projectiles mais effectivement
j'étais derrière les unités de police et
en fait je venais de soigner des
manifestants est en fait il ya eu
beaucoup de projectiles qui ont été
complétés lancé n'ai pas vu beaucoup de
choses et en fait il ya un un chef
d'unité en fait qu'après un pavé sur le
cac s'affiche sur elle son casque et
donc ça a provoqué chez lui un problème
au niveau au niveau de la tête parce que
post traumatique en fait voilà je pense
que ça peut ça peut être dangereux voir
ça peut être pire donc dans ces cas là
on fait évacuer
quel que soit
quelles que soient les interventions
qu'on fait nous secouriste en tout cas
on le fait aussi bien pour la police et
les manifestants
voilà je rappelle parce qu'il ya des
gens qui ont tendance à croire que les
secouristes sont plus orientés côté
police et c'est faux en fait c'est pas
parce que quelqu'un en uniforme que on
va privilégier ces gens là on fait notre
travail des deux côtés moi je suis un
ancien pompier de la marine ont pour moi
soigner un être humain quel que soit son
appartenance
on a vu cet après midi les tirs de feu
d'artifice on a vu des jets de pavés
répliqué avec force de l'ordre ont
répliqué avec des gaz lacrymogènes
comment s'est passé votre après midi
ce que vous avez vu des blessures
sérieuses parce que pourrait nous
expliquer en fait oui eu des blessures
sérieuses des deux côtés donc pour
certains c'est passé à travers les
protections il faut savoir que malgré
les protections que peuvent avoir les
gens la police ou d'autres unités
aussi bien les pompiers aussi ça peut
être dangereux quoi donc
quand on prend un caillou un pavé
n'importe quoi quel que soit le projet
ctif ça peut passer à travers la
protection ou si on côté de la
protection ce qui a été le cas de
nombreuses fois pour eux en tout cas
merci beaucoup david secouriste d'avoir
répondu à nos questions en direct sur rt
france voilà donc pour cet après-midi de
tensions ici place de la bastille où la
situation est en train de revenir au
calme